bonsoir le 7-8 l'actu sur tv fil 78 du
lundi au vendredi l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale voici les titres de
ce nouveau journal de la rédaction
le maire sortant a voisins le bretonneux
l'ump alexis piette face à la
candidature de son ancienne première
adjointe alexandra rosetti mais aussi
celle de jean-louis tison conseiller
municipal de droite jusqu'en 2008 des
élèves du collège sainte thérèse à
rambouillet viennent de participer au
tournage d'un court métrage pour
l'association laurette fugain
association qui se bat afin de
sensibiliser au don de plaquettes et de
moelle dans la lutte contre la leucémie
et puis le don il en sera aussi question
avec nos invités le docteur bhajans ou
berthe et pascal tir et coordinatrice
hospitalière des prélèvements d'organes
le centre hospitalier de versailles
organise le 19 décembre une projection
et débat sur ce thème dans un cinéma de
marly le roi on débute avec l image du
jour et un pique nique géant organisé et
rue de paris à versailles à deux pas du
conseil général et de l'hôtel du
département l'objectif pour les
participants obtenir à la survie de leur
restaurant administratif l'association
qui gère cet établissement a en effet
être déposé le bilan 22 licenciements
sont à craindre la préfecture a déjà
apporté une subvention exceptionnelle de
quelque 20000 euros mais cela n'a pas
suffi et les manifestants ont demandé l
ouverture du restaurant à d'autres
administrations afin d'augmenter le
nombre de clients et donc la rentabilité
de cet établissement est donc la
proposition de la cgt pour retrouver de
l'argent et financer c'est qu'à l'heure
actuelle il ya que le conseil général et
la préfecture qui finance l'association
nous voudrait faire entrer la fois le
mist à l'intérieur parle après la police
sont tous les cas la poste qui mangent
ici la mairie de versailles qui en fasse
pour tout le monde participe au
financement est pas qu aux plateaux
repas pendant les uns les autres amis
station de finances que au niveau déjà
gens qui passent réellement donc avec
tout ça on pense qu'il ya quelque chose
à faire est l'administrateur a dit ce
matin que par rapport aux troubles sur
une dizaine d'années il faudrait 25
centimes par repas pour garder la
structure viable
autre situation économique difficile
celle de l'université de versailles
en yvelines qui affiche un déficit de
plus de 100 millions d'euros et ce mardi
7 décembre est une date importante cet
après-midi se tenait le conseil
d'administration pour voter le budget
2014 une intersyndicale vous le voyez
composé de représentants des étudiants
de professeurs et de personnel à
manifester en début d'après-midi devant
l'ufr des sciences de la santé tout un
symbole d'ailleurs puisque c'est ufr des
sciences à montigny a été réalisée grâce
à un partenariat public privé
un ppp dénoncé aujourd'hui par cette
intersyndicale comme responsable
notamment de peser lourdement dans les
finances difficiles de la faculté les
manifestants s'inquiètent de lourdes
restrictions budgétaires de la
détérioration également de leurs
conditions de travail
ils demandent à la direction de
l'université de porter leur parole au
ministère pour demander que les post a
loué soit réellement pourvu qu un
fléchage des moyens pour le premier
degré soit identifié et que l'offre de
formation ne soit pas réduite nous
reviendrons sur cette mobilisation qui
s'est déroulé à montigny le bretonneux
aujourd'hui devant la faculté de la
santé le point à demain de la suite de
ce conseil d'administration des
décisions prises politique à voisins le
bretonneux une nouvelle liste vient
d'être dévoilée celle de jean-louis
tison il est en ligne avec nos bonsoir à
vous pourquoi ce sera la troisième liste
de droite sur cette commune avec celle
de du maire sortant l'ump alexis piette
celle de son ancienne première adjointe
la centriste alexandra rosetti qui
souhaite d'ailleurs obtenir le soutien
de l'ue dei en revanche vous vous ne
solliciter l'investiture d'aucune
formation pourquoi cette liste de droite
centre-droit indépendante
alors effectivement je conduirai la
lutte de droit paix et centre-droit qui
est la seule véritable vent de droite
pensent eux que alexandre arrosée qui se
positionne au centre vous compte-t-elle
siéger à la communauté de
l'agglomération avec le pl sous avec la
droite il faut choisir et on attend sa
proposition on navigue déjà été maire a
dit nancy lens en ce qui concerne avec
l'idée est pour je crois qu'il est
actuellement à lui ltée il a dans son
équipe le chef de file du modem sa femme
madame bien et effectivement il ya une
confusion puisque vous avez très bien
que le patron du modem a voté hollande
en 2012 qu'elle vous revendus
la seule liste de droite sans trop droit
officiel c'est ce que vous n'avez que ce
soir je tenais à préciser que vous avez
déjà été maire adjoint finances jusqu'en
2007 donc dans l'équipe d'alexis biette
pourquoi vouloir revenir aux affaires et
puis pourquoi aujourd'hui cette
opposition avec celui qui fut votre
allié autrefois avait écouté jeu pour
répondre à votre question préalable
effectivement je ne sollicite aucune
investiture parce que j'entends rester
indépendant garder ma liberté de parole
et assurer ainsi des intérêts de deux
voisins et ses habitants alors en ce qui
concerne alexis viable dont les raisons
pour lesquelles nous sommes séparés en
2007 sont parfaitement claires j'ai
tenté ma chance en 2008 au goût des
jeunes venant on a on a perdu mais je
reviens actuellement en 2014
vous avez des mots durs envers l'équipe
sortante excusez moi on est on est pris
par le temps je voudrais juste à
l'avancé sur cet entretien vous avez des
mots durs envers l'équipe sortante tout
tout est à reprendre en matière
d'urbanisme c'est ce que vous nous dites
en matière fiscale également avec aussi
un objectif de 25 % de logements sociaux
qui est pour vous inatteignable et qui
défigurent aussi sept villes de
voisins-le-bretonneux ce sont là les
principaux axes de votre programme
alors effectivement il ya une gestion un
sucre il ya une augmentation à
supportable des impôts locaux
il faut remettre de l'ordre dans la
maison on peut pas vivre au dessus de
ses moyens alors pour l'urbanisme
effectivement tout est à reprendre
notamment au centre ville il n'est pas
possible d'avoir un système où on a
comme seul objectif de construire 25 %
de logements sociaux la loi sru est
inapplicable à moi de lancer une
spécificité de la ville nouvelle
on ne peut pas avoir 25 % de logements
sociaux bien sûr il faut des logements
sociaux misson construire des logements
mais on peut pas dans le terrain qui
nous restent à voisin atteindre cet
objectif ce qu'il faut développer c'est
plutôt l'identité de voisins identité de
voisins c'est sa proximité des espaces
ruraux des espaces naturels
et en même temps l'opportunité de la
grande ville et l'urbanisme devoir avoir
effectué donc il faut regarder ces deux
visages de la ville juste une dernière
question très brièvement vous ne
craignez pas que cette nouvelle division
de la droite parce que ce n'est pas une
première sur sept villes de voisins le
bretonneux il y aura trois listes de
droite centre droit vous ne craignez pas
que cela pénalise finalement la droite
dans son ensemble
non je ne pense pas parce que chacun
prendra ses responsabilités le moment
venu merci ils ont utilisé d'avoir été
en ligne avec nos candidats aux
municipales à voisins une liste divers
droite vous viendrez en plateau le 7
janvier prochain pour le magazine
municipal 2014
dès 18h30 en direct je vous rappelle que
dès janvier le magazine sera proposé
chaque semaine sur notre antenne
et puis également une quinzaine de
débats à suivre sur les principales
communes du département
ce sera dès le mois de février
municipale toujours avec le parti
socialiste qui a désigné sa tête de
liste pour versailles face au maire
sortant françois de mazières isabelle
this-saint-jean conseiller régional
universitaire elle a aussi été
présidente de sauvons la recherche un
collectif constitué en réaction à la
politique alors du président nicolas
sarkozy et de valérie pécresse ministre
du supérieur
ce duel de mazières this saint jean est
loin d'être inédit les deux candidats se
sont déjà affrontés lors des
législatives
autre sujet l'atelier cinéma du collège
sainte-thérèse de rambouillet est à
l'initiative d'une action au profit de
l'association vive rhinoise d'ailleurs
laurette fugain qui lutte contre la
leucémie 45 élèves âgés de 11 à 16 ans
ont été sélectionnés pour jouer dans ce
court métrage diffusé au cinéma comme
les grands dès le mois de juin le sujet
le regard des autres face à la maladie
yolaine thorez et le dis moi c'est quand
on fait trois actions bon sens vu au
régime avaient lutté
nous sommes en plein tournage au collège
sainte-thérèse de rambouillet 45 élèves
de la 6e à la 3e sont les acteurs d'un
court métrage au profit de l'association
laurette fugain lors de cette scène
chloé arrive en retard en classe et
perturbe le professeur de français pour
les jeunes actrices c'est son tout
premier rôle dans un film je suis une
qui a atteint d'une maladie du sang
assez grave et qui est un peu rejeté par
tout le monde et je suis personnage
principal et je suis la nouvelle
au début je suis un peu versé 8 et puis
après je suis venu la chercheuse des
commandes apprend que je suis atteint de
maladie et moi je supporte pas vraiment
la prochaine fois que vous avez benjamin
a organisé un casting auprès des élèves
de l'atelier cinéma qu'il dirige c'est
lui qui a rédigé la base du scénario au
mois d'août puis les élèves l'ont
complété l'histoire évoque le regard et
le comportement des autres face à la
maladie je voulais pas raconter quelque
chose de dramatique qui traite de la
maladie etc
je voulais faire un quelque chose un
scénario un petit peu humoristique je
demande pour détendre un peu
l'atmosphère et c'est à l'eau non mais
alors quoi nous jouerons le dp est un
défi qui a les bases qui ne l'aiment pas
beaucoup mais on va changer notre regard
sur elle quand on apprend que
dans l'histoire le professeur de
français est joué par un comédien
professionnel lui aussi changent de
regard sur chloé et devient tout de
suite beaucoup plus compréhensif par
rapport à ces retards fin du tournage
prévu au mois de février
le film sera projeté au cinéma de
rambouillet mais aussi à paris dès le
mois de juin 2014
l'intégralité des ventes de places de
cinéma et de dvd sera reversée à
l'association laurette fugain une
diffusion privé au sein du collège est
également programme et nous continuons à
parler du don avec les invités de cette
édition du 17 décembre le docteur
benjamin hubert tout d'abord rebond soit
médecin coordinateur pascal thiery
bonsoir à vous également cantatrice
hospitalière des prélèvements d'organes
et de tissus du centre hospitalier de
versailles
un chiffre tout de même pour débuter est
dit 7627 ce sont les personnes en
attente d'une greffe en 2012 elle était
8733 en 97 conclusion une il n'y a pas
assez de donneurs aujourd'hui votre
présence en plateau en témoigne il faut
expliquer faire de la pédagogie c'est
important pour inciter les gens à donner
tout simplement c'est ça absolument pas
d'abord te remercie de votre invitation
effectivement le la greffe d'organes et
le don d'organes c'est d'abord une
activité croissante vous parliez du
nombre exponentiel presque du nombre
d'inscrits sur la liste en l'espace de
quinze ans il ya parallèlement une
activité de grève qui a augmenté donc là
la médecine a avancé a progressé avec un
nombre plus important de patients
greffés
mais chaque année de plus en plus de
patients sont transplantés et sont
inscrits sur un registre avec une
carence et un une pénurie de greffons
qui vend qui va en augmentant
effectivement je combattrai les chiffres
des données avec plus de 5 me pour la
première fois en 2012 n'a franchi la
barre des 5000 greffes d'organes donc
c'est bien mais effectivement à la fin
de l'année est resté quasiment dix mille
patients inscrits sur la liste
si bien qu'il ya deux tiers des patients
qui restent inscrits avec un organe
défaillant avec leur vie dont qui en
danger par cet organe qui ne marchent
plus est important d'insister la greffe
ça fait d'énormes progrès ces dernières
années ça fonctionne très bien plus de
50000 personnes sont porteuses d'un
greffon fonctionnel en 2012 ce sont des
chiffres issus de l' agence de la
biomédecine
de plus 42 % de grève 121 en france
également
ça fonctionne très bien est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya encore des
réticences parce que les gens se disent
que finalement donné ça va ne pas servir
à grand chose
quels sont les critères qui explique les
refus parfois je crois malheureusement
plus le refus s'explique surtout par une
absence de positionnement de son vivant
et c'est vraiment là c'est on va
probalement y revenir mais les campagnes
de l'allant de la biomédecine et notre
fonction de d unité de coordination
hospitalière
c'est de sensibiliser les français à ce
projet de leur vivant s'il leur arrive
un accident
quels sont ils pour ou contre le don
d'organes les concernant concernant leur
corps pour pâques les familles en deuil
et dans un contexte souvent de morts
brutales et a tranché et par défaut
malheureusement parfois ils disent non
alors peut-être que le patient aurait pu
l'être vivant pouvoir donner ses organes
alors comment ça se passe justement
concrètement comment ça fonctionne le
don d'organes tissu sachant que cela
repose tout même sur une loi depuis 1976
sur un principe du consentement présumé
c'est à dire si on ne déclare pas son
refus on peut être privée alors ça c'est
aussi sens c'est ce que dit la loi
stricto sensu effectivement à la loi
elle est basée comme vous l'avez très
bien dit sur le consentement présumé
c'est un français qui ne s'est pas
exprimé clairement compte le don
d'organes de son vivant en pratique
s'être inscrit sur le registre national
des refus auprès d'agents de la
biomédecine peut être prélevée en
pratique on comprend bien con
qu'on ne peut pas passer outre
l'information de la famille est plus que
le consentement c'est essayer de savoir
quelles étaient les volontés du malade
donc s'est interrogé vérifier l'absence
de refus du patient de son vivant auprès
des proches
maintenant quand le patient ne s'est pas
créé de son vivant balle est proche sur
une situation délicate puisqu'il finit
c'est eux qui on a tranché et parfois
ils décident ils disent non nous ne
préférons pas ou n'ont peut-être qu'il
n'aurait pas et comme noah va parler on
préfère dire non et ce serait beaucoup
plus simple si tous les français
pouvaient se positionner et dire à leurs
proches à leurs frères soeurs père mère
ou femmes ce qui est ce qu'ils en
pensent et se positionner mais même si
de son vivant un donneur déclare vouloir
justement faire ce geste ce don si la
famille refuse après ça se passe comment
c'est possible c'est compliqué mais
c'est rare et là encore je crois que la
famille
les familles souvent sont quand même
tiennent à se porter garant des
dernières volontés du patient et nous
dans ce cas là on est c'est
effectivement de centrer le débat sur
les dernières volontés du patient et si
elle s'était très clairement en faveur
du don d'organes virement les familles
se plie à ses bontés là et ils vont dans
le sens de la volonté du malade
ce que je voudrais savoir c'est comment
vous intervenez auprès des familles
quels sont les mots employés pour
expliquer faire de la pédagogie en plus
il faut aller très vite lorsqu'il ya eu
le décès bon ça se passe concrètement
chacun notre rôle chacun sur le terrain
alors nous trop de vols
moi je suis médecin qu'on adore je suis
également rénovateurs donc vote d'hier
succès des entretiens qui sont
effectivement compliquons pas sinon
compliqué en tout cas important et
devant faire intervenir à la fois la
coordination et les réanimateurs leur
animateur dans un premier temps doit
s'assurer que les proches ont bien
compris la réalité du décès ce qu on
appelle on n'a pas rester le dessus mais
les prélèvements d'organes concernent
des patients en mort de mort
encéphalique donc les patients sont à
coeur qui bat encore grâce à la reine
mation notamment la ventilation qui fait
que le coeur bat et continue à rendre
viables les différents organes alors
même qu'il n'y a plus aucune vie
cérébrale donc on doit s'assurer de la
véracité que les proches ont compris
l'irréversibilité la réalité de la mort
et ensuite on aborde et ça c'est
vraiment le rôle de la coordination
on aborde la recherche de non opposition
auprès des proches faisaient ce qu'on
prêtait justement alors au niveau des
entretiens c'est vrai que c'est un petit
peu c'est difficile parce que ce sont
toujours des circonstances brutale avec
une annonce de décès qui arrive souvent
rapidement après le après l'accident et
nous arrivons derrière avec les médecins
pour pour effectivement par les dons
d'organes
une fois que les proches ont bien
compris c'est pas simple que leur part
leurs parents est décédé on aborde le
problème du don en général on pose
directement la question mais bon on a
pas systématiquement de réponse facile
on s du temps aux proches pour ce pour
réfléchir
simplement comme le disait l'auteur
hubert bien souvent ne connaissent pas
ce que voulait la personne décédée est
là à ce moment là on essaye de savoir ce
qu'ils auraient pu en penser s'il en
avait parlé et que ça fait quand même
beaucoup de conditionnel et dans des
circonstances difficiles comme ça on a
souvent des réponses je ne sais pas ce
qu'ils voulaient je ne veux pas prendre
la décision de sa place je ne veux pas
alors il vaut mieux agir de son vivant
avec cette carte de donneur d'organes et
de tissus de l' agence de la biomédecine
qui existe également une carte de
donneur d'organes et de tissus de
l'association de france la dot reconnue
d'utilité publique depuis 1978 est
également un passeport de vie de la
fondation greffe de vie où les éléments
si vous souhaitez faire savoir que vous
souhaitez à donner après après votre
mort et puis la carte césar aussi
aujourd'hui il est possible avec une
carte la carte vitale
la deuxième génération de la carte
vitale de le signaler auprès de son
médecin pour l'instant c'était encore en
discussion pour l'instant sané ça n'est
pas effectif
par contre qui est aussi un plus ça
pourrait être ça pourrait peut-être
servir mais c'est pas c'est pas
obligatoire enfin moi ça me semble un
peu plus compliqué parce que ce qui
compte d'abord c'est l'information des
personnes vous allez clé les gens
peuvent avoir une certaine méfiance en
disant oh je sais pas trop ce que c'est
je préfère dire non alors que à la base
ce qui est important si c'est de
discuter d'informer les gens parce que
les gens ont encore quelques pour
certains des mauvaises idées par rapport
au don d'organes alors que c'est c'est
une chirurgie kiprop alors que c'est un
acte vraiment tout à fait respectueux
par rapport aux défunts votre travail
porte sur le fait de sensibiliser
l'entourage les familles on l'a compris
l importance de la greffe dans ce cadre
il y aura d'ailleurs une projection de
données
se voir le 19 décembre à 20h30 au cinéma
le fonctionnel de marly le roi vous
allez y participer pour animer un débat
d'ailleurs on va voir des images de
cette bande annonce de ce film de michel
et bernard dal molin est ce que vous
pouvez déjà nous en dire plus que
retrace ce film ce sont des témoignages
alors ce sont des témoignages davantage
de ce film c'est qu'en fait ils reposent
sur l'humain il ya eu quelques quelques
films qui ont été faits sur le sujet
mais qui était très pratico pratique ou
avec des deux côtés un côté médical la
cette histoire est assez histoire repose
vraiment sur l'humain sur l'expérience
des personnes qui vont accepter les dons
d'organes sur des personnes greffées et
c'est le côté humain qui est très
intéressant dans ce sens ce film et ça
peut faire changer les mentalités
le film déjà rien qu'on lui même ça peut
aider à changer les mentalités et puis
surtout après on sera là pour discuter
avec les personnes de docteur hubert
quoi répondent aux questions par rapport
à la mort cérébrale parce que c'est pas
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
peu connu nous serons là pour pour
expliquer comment se fait la prise en
charge des proches comment se fait la
prise en charge du défunt du début
jusqu'à la fin
c'est comment aussi pour rassurer
certaines certainement les personnes
quelles sont les questions sont vous
pose le plus souvent pour conclure
justement à l'issue de ces débats ces
rencontres que vous pouvez avoir avec le
grand public
il ya beaucoup de questions sur la
religion il ya beaucoup de questions sur
le rendu du corps comment est-ce que
comment est ce qu'il va être après
d'ailleurs ont longtemps
systématiquement dans les entretiens
comment est ce qu'il va être après c'est
vraiment un souci important pour les
proches merci à tous les deux est revenu
sur ce plateau nous ont parlé on va
juste pour conclure ce plateau consacrée
au don d'organes à la greffe regarder un
court extrait de cette bande annonce du
film donner recevoir qui sera projeté le
19 décembre au cinéma le fontenelle à
marly-le-roi merci aux cordes mais si on
remercie
ça a été vraiment non non j'ai au début
je pensais je pensais que ça allait pas
se faire mais je partais tout doucement
je m'étais résigné je portais toute
façon on en attente d'un organe on se
pose beaucoup de questions ce que c'est
au point est ce que ça va se faire aussi
déjà ce qu'on va avoir la chance d'être
d'être sauvé est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
donneur mais un passage où on s'en veut
même on s'en veut de se dire j'attends
quelqu'un 17 pour voir être sauvé
c'est dur comme question c'est quand
même dur de penser à ça
économie à présent consommer durable
pendant les fêtes c'est possible à
bazens ville à la ferme du loup
ravissant comme c'est charmant le foie
gras est produit de façon traditionnelle
et en circuits courts une méthode
qu'elle semble de plus en plus apprécié
les consommateurs comme nous l'expliqué
olivier maniscalco et elodie moines
pascal lecoq et producteurs de foie gras
à bazens ville s'est produit il les vend
directement sur sa ferme
c'est ce qu'on appelle le circuit court
pas d'intermédiaire entre lui et ses
consommateurs et un rapport direct avec
ses clients pour expliquer ou faire
visiter son exploitation chez lui le
foie gras est traditionnelle les canards
sont nourris avec des céréales locales
et du maïs entier produits et séchez
directement dans sa ferme un mode de
fabrication qui permet un foie gras de
qualité et les clients apprécient les
gens aujourd'hui veulent savoir où ils
achètent ils ne veulent plus des
transports terminaux dans des conditions
plus ou moins du feu et puis parfois des
produisent donc c'est pas réellement
l'origine aujourd'hui veulent savoir
d'où ça vient
ils veulent que ce soit de la qualité
ils ont raison aujourd'hui on est même
approcher de plus en plus par la grande
distribution ils voudraient qu'on
produise un peu mais de toute façon ce
sera qu'un tout petit peu pour eux parce
qu'on ne peut pas n'a pas les capacités
de le faire et après on dévalorise
rendre notre produit six enfants se
mettait à faire des quantités trop
importantes la qualité de son foie gras
a cependant un coût
en moyenne ces produits sont de 30 à 50%
plus cher que dans une grande surface en
france d'après l'agencé de
l'environnement
les achats en circuits courts représenté
en 2010 environ 7% des achats
alimentaires
la maison des jeunes et de la culture
des clayes-sous-bois organisé ce week
end la deuxième édition du royaume du
jeu l'occasion pour les petits et les
grands la formule est consacrée de se
retrouver autour de célèbre jeu de
société juste pour le plaisir de jouer
anthony rey jonathan vilma en ont
profité pour faire une partie c'était
une invitation de croisade à travers les
époques le royaume du jeu offraient toc
les siens petits et grands une occasion
de rêver de grandes batailles sur cette
table quelques joueurs se livrent une
guerre de territoire à la conquête
d'abbaye de près
deux chemins pour tout joueur digne de
ce nom il faut évidemment posséder un
certain talent pour remporter la partie
il ya beaucoup de hasard mais aussi
beaucoup de stratégie par exemple si je
pioche
cette carte la fiche de la mélasse fini
son château à lui alors que ça
m'intéresse pas du tout moi je préférais
finir mon château à moi qui est là
quelques tables plus loin ce jeu
d'équilibré à destination des plus
jeunes est l occasion de jouer avec les
parents donc le principe c'est de
choisir une couleur donc avec 1,2 et en
plus si on tombe sur le verre on va
tirer une pie verte
mais il faut pas que ouistiti ton celui
qui gagne à la fin c'est celui qui a le
moins de risques éthiques
évidemment il y a toujours la
satisfaction de ne pas faire tomber ce
sacré ouistiti lorsqu on le retire une
paille que l'on gagne ou que l'on perde
le plaisir de jouer prend toujours le
pas au royaume du jeu
chanter noël une tradition également
tiède l'association culture et tradition
d'outre-mer n'a pas manqué ce
rendez-vous c'était samedi soir à
montigny le bretonneux
elle
à l'entrée on remet à chacun son livret
de quantic le chanter noël une tradition
antillaise qui perdure en métropole
comme ici à montigny par le biais de
l'association culture et tradition
d'outre-mer un bain de bonne humeur
entre chansons traditionnelles danses et
plats typiques
c'est un moment de partage ces moments
de retrouvailles il ya également un
petit
c'est vraiment y rappelle également eu
de noël par rapport à la religion donc
les les choses sont à la fois
bagnols
chrétien ya des champs spécifiques
il ya moins d'échangés
comme par exemple le fameux petit petit
papa noël mais il y a des izia des
couplets qu'on appelle des ritournelles
et ses ritournelles chanté en créole
donc il ya vraiment un mélange de
langues de change de rythme
non
des chants des danses et un repas pris
en commun pour du fait maison autour de
la préparation du jambon des boudins du
pâtis salé ou du fameux cochon aussi
préparé avec du riz et des pois d'angole
uniquement récoltés pendant la période
de décembre
ça replonge dans l'ambiance
et noël traditionnels
commun
au pays ça rappelle des souvenirs pertes
voyager les gens de garder un peu de
cette culture renard et
à la salle du pain mais de faire
connaître et de faire connaître la
culture mais je les ai toujours faire de
pétain tout petit mes parents m'ont
inculqué un peu la culture antillaise
malgré que je sois né ici
et ben moi je continue avec il est en
fait ce petit passeport qui vous donner
on
mon groupe
oh
et plus qu'une semaine à attendre avant
noël en attendant le journal revient
demain 18h toujours en direct excellente
soirée sur téléphiles